est il justement vous en rêvez et
direction en l'île de groix face à
lorient dans le morbihan
ça reste accessible aussi les touristes
sont de plus en plus nombreux à
embarquer en direction des îles
bretonnes les amateurs de randonnées à
pied ou en bicyclette
il trouve un petit coin de paradis
pascal coup-ci aussi port de lorient
embarquement pour l' aventure certes
l'île de groix n'est qu'à quelques
encablures
mais rien de tel que le pont d'un navire
pour se sentir l'âme d'hommes baroudeur
la traversée ne dure que 45 minutes mais
à l'arrivée à port tudy on a changé de
monde avec l'impression d'avoir traversé
tout un océan sur toutes les ondes et il
le trafic a augmenté durant les quatre
cinq dernières années avec pour voir une
particularité où on a un droit
rechercher un côté nature tourisme vert
une grande fréquentation de randonneurs
de gens en vélo car le touriste des îles
n'est pas celui de la côte s'il vient
ici c'est justement pour fuir la foule
de ses congénères agglutinés sur le
sable changer d'ère regarder les oiseaux
et prendre son temps en flânant dans la
lande pour les touristes une île c'est
un peu un autre monde donc c'est une
complète découverte ils ne savent pas du
tout ce qu'ils vont voir
et quand il aborde
lille
ils ont toujours plein de questions
oui c'est un autre tourisme
un autre tourisme en plein essor depuis
cinq ans à groix le nombre des visiteurs
est en progression chaque été même si
les plus nombreux ne font qu'un simple
aller retour dans la journée le temps
d'un grand bol d'air
on a à part de tout le monde ce
tranquille il n'y a pas de mai
tranquille sa tranquillité - droiture
aussi bien qu'il y en ait quelques unes
moins de voitures pas de camion pas du
tyne et puis une ambiance aussi sur une
île c'est comme un grand paquebot isolée
au milieu de l'océan et les gens ont une
dimension et natures différentes que
sont le continent
la preuve ici même en plein mois d'août
il y encore beaucoup de place sur la
plage